merci
[Musique]
beaucoup bonjour vous allez bien ça va
et vous
oui et notre invité politique ce matin
c'est François Xavier béami bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous députés
européens tête de liste des républicains
pour les élections européennes on va
évidemment commencer par la loi
immigration François Xavier béami on
parlera de la crise agricole dans
quelques instant le Conseil
constitutionnel qui a donc censuré hier
une grande partie des mesures de la loi
immigration et sur tout les mesures
ajoutées par la droite sénatoriale c'est
un un rev un camouflé pour vous cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
c'est c'est une défaite immense pour la
France pour la démocratie française et
cette décision en réalité est révoltante
c'est un coup d'état institutionnel qui
viole je le dis ici la lettre et
l'esprit de notre Constitution il ne
s'agit pas ici d'expliquer qu'il y
aurait d'un côté la politique et de
l'autre le droit il y a un conseil
constitutionnel qui s'assiit sur la
Constitution française parce que pour
que tout le monde nous comprenne bien ce
que le Conseil constitutionnel explique
aujourd'hui c'est que les articles que
nous avons effectivement fait adopter
parce que les parlementaires
républicains ici au Sénat à l'Assemblée
nationale les ont ajouté à ce texte sur
l'immigration ce texte qui était au
départ un texte de régularisation
massive nous en avons fait l'occasion
par les propositions que nous formulions
de mieux maîtriser les flux migratoires
en travaillant sur la restriction de
l'accès au regroupement familial sur le
durcissement des conditions d'accès à la
nationalité française sur la question de
la déchéance de nationalité pour des
personnes qui ayant acquis la
nationalité française se rendaient
coupable de crime contre les policiers
ou les gendarmes tout cela nous l'avons
fait entrer dans la loi pour en faire un
texte qui correspondait toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion l'ont montré à ce
qu'attendent les Français et que dit le
Conseil constitutionnel au lieu de se
prononcer sur le fond sans aucune
justification il explique que tous ces
articles sont des cavalier législatif
c'estàdire qu'il n'avait pas de lien
avec l'objet du texte mais à qui le
Conseil constitutionnel va faire croire
que la question du regroupement familial
le fait de faire en sorte que des
étrangers ai besoin de cotiser avant de
percevoir des prestations sociales que
le fait de sanctionner l'entrée
irrégulière sur le se français que
toutes ces questions là n'auraient pas
de lien avec l'immigration mais qui peut
croire ça c'est évidemment une forme de
mensonge monstrueux c'est une hypocrisie
scandaleuse dont le seul effet est de
désarmer l'État avec la complicité du
président de la République qui a voulu
envoyer ce texte à la censure du Conseil
constitutionnelle et aujourd'hui il n'y
a qu'un seul perdant dans cette affaire
c'est la France ce sont les Français
c'est la possibilité pour l'état de
maîtriser ses frontières c'est le fait
que les citoyens puissent obtenir ce
qu'ils attendent et c'est évidemment
notre démocratie parlementaire parce que
cette loi elle a été votée par le
Parlement par la majorité parlementaire
elle a été votée en accord avec ce que
les Français attendaient aujourd'hui par
une sorte de subterfuge de procédure on
se retrouve devant eff cou dé
institutionnel ce que vous dites c'est
c'est fort Franch mais vous dites quoi
que que le Conseil constitutionnel a
fait de la politique est allé hors de
l'État de droit mais qui qui ne le voit
pas et encore une fois je le redis
reprenons l'article 45 l'article 45 dont
dont on parle maintenant parce que il
faut rentrer dans la technique l'article
45 qui est le motif de cette censure du
Conseil constitutionnel il dit que tout
amendement est recevable en première
lecture s'il a un lien même indirect
avec l'objet de la loi même indirect
c'était une réforme de 2008 qui voulait
précisément rétablir les droits des
parlementaires qui doivent pouvoir
amender un texte ce soir on a perdu hier
soir pardon on a on a perdu le le
Parlement français on l'a perdu pourquoi
parce que on avait déjà des 493 à
répétition on avait déjà un gouvernement
qui légiférait par ordonnance sans
jamais soumettre ses textes au contrôle
du Parlement comme pourtant la
Constitution li oblige et maintenant on
a le Conseil constitutionnel qui vient
de supprimer virtuellement le droit
d'Amand ement le Conseil constitutionnel
en fait détruit la lettre et l'esprit de
l'article de 45 et de la réforme de 2008
encore une fois je le redis aucun
Français ne peut sérieusement penser que
les sujets dont nous parlons n'avaient
pas de rapport avec l'objet d'un texte
sur l'immigration ça n'a aucun sens et
donc aujourd'hui évidemment le Conseil
constitionnel prend une responsabilité
immense d'ailleurs celle qui celle qui
celle qui consiste à à dire à tous les
Français parce que c'est ce qu'ils
comprendront que en réalité
nos institutions empêchent notre propre
état de se réarmer pour reprendre une
expression en vogue aujourd'hui que nos
institutions désarmment l'État et
retirent aux Français la possibilité de
décider de leur politique migratoire
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demandons comme nous le faisons depuis
des années qu'un référendum puisse avoir
lieu sur la politique migratoire et qui
que nous puissions réformer la cons on
va revenir làdessus est-ce que vous
dites comme Laurent voquier qu'il faut
que ce soit le Parlement qui est le
dernier mot sur le Conseil
constitutionnel et est-ce que c'est pas
là sortir de l'état de drit actuel bien
sûr que non Laurent vquier a
parfaitement raison ce que Laurent
vquier dit c'est que mais ça veut dire
ça revient il faut supprimer le Conseil
constitutionnel il sert à rien non ce
que Laurent vquier dit c'est que
l'Assemblée et le Sénat réunis ensemble
dans la formation qui est celle du
Congrès donc du constituant doivent
pouvoir corriger une décision
jurisprudentielle du Conseil
constitutionnel et aujourd'hui on n'aura
pas d'autre choix que d'en passer par là
parce qu'on peut
pas sur le fonctionnement de la 5e à à
l'heure actuelle qui est que le Conseil
constitutionnel a le dernier mot sur les
lois votées par le Parlement le dernier
mot appartient au constituant bien sûr
le Conseil constitutionnel il est là
pour appliquer la Constitution et quand
la Constitution est manifestement violée
par le Conseil constitutionnel lui-même
alors le constituant doit prendre ses
responsabilités Val que les lois voté
par le Parlement ne pas la Constitution
dans C cas qui est le constituant en
France c'est le Congrès c'est-à-dire
l'Assemblée et le Sénat réunis ensemble
pour pouvoir exprimer la volonté
souveraine du peuple et qui valide que
les lois votées par le Parlement ne
violent pas la Constitution si c'est le
Parlement qui a le dernier mot mais
encore une fois je le redis c'est pas le
Parlement dans sa forme ordinaire
c'est-à-dire la navette entre
l'Assemblée et le Sénat c'est la réunion
des deux chambres qui constituent le
Congrès qui a le pouvoir constituant et
je le redis aujourd'hui il est
parfaitement clair et le Conseil
constitutionnel l'assume d'ailleurs la
jurisprudence est récente elle date d'il
y a seulement quelques mois en réalité
c'est seulement depuis quelques mois que
le Conseil constitutionnel a pris sur
lui la décision de considérer qu'un
cavalier législatif c'était pas
seulement un amendement voté à
l'extérieur de l'objet de la loi mais un
amendement qui ne correspondrait pas à
un article de la loi initiale à une
disposition du texte initial ce qui
donne en fait une prime incroyable au
gouvernement le gouvernement peut
décider tout seul de la loi c'est ce que
nous dit aujourd'hui le Conseil
constitionnel et pardon de le dire
pardon de le dire mais quand je vois le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald armanin
hier chez vos confrères de TF1 qui se
réjouit de la censure du Conseil
constitutionnel contre une loi qu'il a
dit
soutenir qui se réjouit que le Conseil
constitutionnel et désarmé l'État face à
l'immigration et qu'il est empêcher
l'état de limiter y compris
l'immigration légale le jour même le
jour même où nous apprenons qu'en 2023
nous avons connu un nombre record
d'entrées illégal et légal sur le
territoire français et bien je dis qu'en
réalité le ministre de l'Intérieur
incarne exactement tout ce que les gens
ne veulent plus
voir tout ce que les gens ne veulent
plus voir parce qu'ils ont
jou il dit que son texte a été validé
par le Conseil constitutionnel personne
ne croit une seconde que c'est parce que
les oppositions ont forcé c'est le mot
qui loyé hier les oppositions
c'est-à-dire les LR pour faire rentrer
d'autres mesures qu'on en arrive à cette
censure mais vous vous rendez compte de
la gravité de ce
terme où sont les facieux aujourd'hui
puisque c'est cela qui nous est parfois
reproché quand nous discutons une
décision du Conseil constitionnel ce qui
est pourtant parfaitement légitime en
démocratie où sont ceux qui jouent avec
nos institutions où ce sont qui violent
l'esprit de nos institutions ils sont
précisément au gouvernement et Monsieur
Darmanin en réalité a joué avec ce qui
est qui est pourtant fondamental pour
les Français la question migratoire a
joué avec une loi qu'il prétendait
défendre et qu'aujourd'hui manifestement
il dit avoir en réalité chercher dès le
départ à saper et bien nous nous avons
fait le travail nous nous avons pris au
sérieux les Français nous avons pris au
sérieux cette loi nous nous avons posé
des propositions nous avons fait avancer
nos idées et aujourd'hui nous le disons
nous avons mené le bon combat nous avons
est que vousz pas fait une erreur de
stratégie a parce que par exemple sur la
réforme de laame vous avez négocié avec
le gouvernement pour que ce soit une
réforme à part parce que vous savez que
ça ça all être inconstitutionnel est-ce
que vous n'auriez pas dû faire ça sur
d'autres propositions du texte négocier
avec le gouvernement un projet de loi à
part pour pas que ce ne soit considérés
comme des cavaliers législatifs je le
redis d'abord il y avait aucune évidence
dans cette décision nous avons défendu
la loi devant le Conseil constitutionnel
nous l'avons fait parce que le
gouvernement lui pour le coup ce qui est
un cas assez unique dans l'histoire de
la 5e République a saisi le Conseil
constitionnel luiême même et ensuite a
défendu la loi d'une manière extrêmement
modeste disons-le nous nous avons
défendu cette loi le fait est que
effectivement laame touchait directement
la politique de la santé il était normal
d'en faire un texte à part maintenant ce
que je demande au gouvernement si
vraiment il veut que la France puisse de
nouveau décider de la maîtrise des flux
migratoires c'est de faire de ce texte
de laame qui doit et c'est un engagement
et il faut qu'il soit tenu qui doit
venir sur le buau de l'Assemblée et du
Sénat il faut que dans ce texte sur
laame soit réintroduites les
dispositions qui ont été censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel parce que
quasiment aucun soci regrou famr bien
sûr aucune de celles que vous évoqué et
quasiment aucune des dispositions
censurées par le Conseil constitutionnel
ne l'a été au fond c'est trop facile
d'ailleurs pour le Conseil
constitutionnel parce que de fait il
s'exonère de toute nécessité de
justifier sa décision maintenant aucune
de ces dispositions n'a été dite être
contraire au principe à l'esprit à la
lettre de la Constitution il faut donc
en refaire un texte à part pour que plus
personne ne puisse dire qu'il s'agissait
de cavalier évidemment ce prétexte est
fallacieux mais puisque ce prétexte
était fallacieux raison de plus pour
remettre sur la table c'est toi que je
le rappelle les Français
attendent fermé la porte hier il a dit
il y aura pas de nouveau projet de loi
immigration d'abord il doit y avoir un
texte sur la me on l'attend mais est-ce
que remettre dans un texte sur la me des
prestations sociales des réformes du
droit du sol du regroupement familial ça
sera pas à nouveau considéré comme un
CAV faisons du coup de ce texte sur
laame un texte plus large sur les
questions migratoires avec ses
dispositions dès le départ du texte et a
priori du coup la le Conseil
constitutionnel serait sera bien cette
fois-ci malgré euh ce coup de force
improbable incapable de le de de le
censurer donc vous demandez une réforme
plus large que la réforme de la M de
toute façon je vais vous dire une chose
les Français attendent cette réforme ils
savent que nous en avons besoin dans les
deux dernières années 1 million de
personnes sont rentré en France
légalement 1 million ce qui veut dire
que nous sommes arrivés à des niveaux
d'immigration absolument record
évidemment qu'il faut réagir cette loi
que nous avions construite non pas
forcée construite cette loi loi elle
était approuvée toutes les enquêtes
l'ont montré par 70 % des Français et
ceux qui se réjouissent comme le
ministre de l'Intérieur ceux qui disent
qu'ils sont satisfaits de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel sont en train de
dire en fait qu'ils sont satisfaits que
le peuple français ne puisse pas
s'exprimer sur le sujet que le peuple
français n'est pas ce qu'il souhaitait
pour pouvoir faire en sorte de décider
de nouveau de son destin sur ce sujet
absolument crucial donc encore une fois
je le redis la situation est est
révoltante moi je je suis vraiment
écœuré de l'hypocrisie du spectacle
indécent auquel nous assistons depuis
quelques heures
révolté je suis aussi je dois dire un
peu découragé parce qu' avec les
parlementaires républicains avec brune
rotaillot avec Olivier marlex avec Eric
sootti nous avions fait ce travail avec
détermination avec sérieux et et au fond
il y a quelque chose de on était
peut-être effectivement vous l'avez dit
peut-être on a été d'une certaine
manière trop sérieux peut-être qu'on a
pris trop au sérieux le contenu de ces
sujets peut-être qu'on n pas soupçonné
le degré d'hypocrisie dont ce
gouvernement était capable pour ma part
je n'ai jamais cru moi qu'aucune
alliance n'était possible avec le
macronisme vous ontendu un piège
Emmanuel Macron et Géral ils vous ont
tendu un piège ils ont cherché à avoir
votre soutien tout en sachant que vos
mesures étaient inconstitutionnelles et
que c'est leur texte au final qui serit
validé vous êtes tombé dans un piège du
gouvernement peut-être mais c'est la
France qui tombe dans le piège et en
réalité je je je crois que on on ne peut
pas dire assez la gravité de ce qui
vient de se passer de la gravité de ce
qui vient de se passer pour notre droit
parlementaire pour notre vie
institutionnelle pour la la démocratie
représentative que nous serions supposer
vivre comment est-ce qu'on peut croire
encore comment est-ce que les Français
peuvent croire encore que nous sommes
une démocratie représentative quand ce
texte voté par le Parlement approuvé par
70 % des Français est en réalité avec
l'enthousiasme du gouvernement détruite
par le Conseil constitutionnel tout ça
aura des conséquences
malheureusement qui son assent les
conséences pour demain est-ce que ça va
marquer une rupture de confiance entre
les républicains et l'exécutif est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui les républicains vont
continuer à coconstruire des textes avec
l'exécutif oui nous nous sommes dans
l'opposition ce texte il n' pas ét
l'osition mais sur les retraites vous
avez construit avec eux sur
l'immigration vous avez construit avec
eux est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les relations
vont changerc une fois je le redit nous
sommes dans l'opposition ce texte sur
l'immigration nous l'avons obtenu par un
bras de fer avec le gouvernement parce
que le gouvernement ne voulait pas faire
ça et s'il y a une bonne nouvelle parce
qu'il y a quand même une bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'au moins le texte que voulait
Gérald daranin qui était un texte de
régularisation massive qui cré un droit
opposable à la régularisation au moins
ce texte là il est tombé pour le coup ça
n'existe plus c'estàdire que dans le
texte tel qu'il sera promulgué il n'y a
pas de droit opposable à la
régularisation nous aurons au moins
évité le pire mais ce meilleur que nous
voulions pour les Français ce progrès
que nous espérions ce renforcement de
notre politique migratoire lui pour le
coup il a été détruit et encore une fois
je le redis c'est notre démocratie qui
tombe dans le piège tombé est-ce que ça
va changer vos relations avec l'exécutif
est-ce que vous voterez encore
aujourd'hui des texes du gouvernement
nous encore à les amender nous resterons
dans une opposition déterminée nous l'
nous l'avons été nous le sommes toujours
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui plus plus
ridicule que jamais c'est tous les gens
qui voudraient nous faire croire parce
que par petite qu par petite tactique
personnelle ils ont rejoint ce
gouvernement cette majorité en étant
issue de la droite et qui voudrait nous
faire croire que ce gouvernement est de
droite ceuxl pour le coup ils sont
désavoués ils sont ridicules c'est
absurde ce gouvernementti qui est
ridicule mais par exemple mais c'est
Gérald daranin c'est Bruno Le Maire
c'est tous ceux qui viennent de la
droite et qui voudrait nous faire croire
que ce gouvernement fait quoi que ce
soit qui pourrait répondre aux
aspirations des Français mais ceuxa en
réalité ils ont ils ont tout trahi et
ils emmènent aujourd'hui notre
démocratie toute entiè à l'abîe
maintenant il faut tout changer il faut
tout refaire il faudra tout reconstruire
et commencer d'ailleurs par reconstruire
la confiance des Français envers leurs
institutions ça voudra dire justement
créer les les conditions d'une
alternance qui fasse que demain nous
aurons de nouveau des hommes d'État des
hommes et des femmes d'état des gens qui
s'engagent en politique pour pouvoir
tenir leur part parole pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que les choses avancent
et pas pour jouer ce Billère à quatre
bandes désolant auquel on assiste depuis
quelques heures un dernier mot là-dessus
puisque vous demandez une réforme de la
Constitution est-ce que c'est pas une
demande veine vous avez essayé de faire
une proposition loi constitutionnelle
vous les républicains à l'Assemblée au
Sénat en décembre elle n'est passée dans
aucune des deux chambres mais comment
vous allez réussir à réformer la
Constitution il ne vous aura pas échappé
que nous ne sommes pas majoritair
aujourd'hui et que vous n'avez aucune
majorité qui soutient cette réformme de
la Constitution y compris vos alliés
centristes ici au Sénat not notre but
notre notre travail c'est et tout le
monde voit très bien ce travail est
nécessaire de préparer une alternance
d'incarner une alternative et la
proposition de loi constitutionnel que
nous avons mis sur la table aujourd'hui
chacun peut s'en saisir mais je vois
bien que le
gouvernement pourquoi et pourquoi parce
que dans cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle nous avons un but très
simple qui est
d'élargir d'élargir le champ du
référendum pour qu'il puisse être ouvert
aux questions migratoires et que les
Français puissent se prononcer sur la
politique migratoire par référendum
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas possible et
pourtant tout le monde plus la primuté
du droit national sur le droit européen
en matière
d'immigration ce que nous disons c'est
que lorsque la jurisprudence des cours
européennes va manifestement contre la
possibilité de décider de notre propre
politique migratoire alors le
constituant c'est-à-dire ici en dernier
ressort le peuple français doit pouvoir
prendre la décision parce que la
Constitution est supérieure y compris au
traités européens et ça pour le coup
c'est évidemment déjà le le cas ça ne
change rien à ce que nous avons validé
par nos engagements internationaux mais
encore une fois je le redis notre but
c'est de redonner la parole au peuple
français et à la fin le général de
Gaulle le disait le dernier et le
meilleur euh juge suprême la meilleure
des cours suprêmes en démocratie c'est
le peuple et donc il faut que dans une
démocratie en pleine santé le peuple
puisse s'exprimer sur les sujets les
plus importants pour l'avenir et
l'immigration en fait évidemment partie
aujourd'hui l'autre actualité c'est
cette crise agricole et ces blocages qui
se durcissent et qui se multiplient hier
Gérald armanin a dit au 20 qu'il
n'interviendrait pas qu'il n'enverrait
pas les forces de l'ordre contre les
agriculteurs il a raison mais d'abord ce
dont les agriculteurs ont besoin c'est
de réponse aux problèmes qu'ils sont en
train de crier merci infiniment les les
les les les problèmes qui les touchent
aujourd'hui on va venir sur le fond mais
sur la manière il y a on a vu hier des
préfectures qui ont été attaquées
notamment à Bordeaux notamment à agin
Gérald permanent dit ils ne s'enprennent
pas au policiers ils ne s'enprennent pas
aux gendarmes ils ne s'enprennent pas au
bien publics je n'enverra pas les forces
de l'ordre est-ce que vous approuvez
cette stratégie mais moi je le redis
aujourd'hui ce dont les les agriculteurs
ont besoin ça n'est pas d'abord d'une
réponse du ministre de l'intérieur mais
d'abord d'une réponse du ministre de
l'agriculture et du Premier ministre et
du président de la République qui fasse
qu'enfin il puisse obtenir des réponses
au problèmes qu'ils sont en train de
criéer vous savez les vous défendez
l'autorité de l'État chez l'R et vous
fravier bami vous vous dites il faut
faire respecter l'autorité de l'État
est-ce que là l'autorité de l'État est
respectée quand il y a des préfectures
qui son vous savez les agriculteurs
français s'ils ont des tracteurs c'est
pas pour bloquer les autoroutes et si
ils font du fumier c'est pas pour le
mettre devant des préfectures leur but à
eux c'est de cultiver la terre et ils
travaillent déjà suffisamment pour ça et
s'ils en arrivent là c'est parce que
personne dans ce gouvernement personne
dans cette majorité n'a voulu les
écouter pour nous les républicain ça
fait des années que nous tirons la
sonnette d'alarme des années cette crise
du monde agricole cette colère qui
s'exprime je dois dire avec tristesse
évidemment mais elle ne me surprend pas
déjà en 2020 j'ai retrouvé une
intervention au Parlement européen en
2020 je disais la folie de cette
stratégie de décroissance agricole dans
laquelle était en train de s'engager
l'Europe et dans laquelle la France a
voulu s'engager la première parce que le
gouvernement français voulait toujours
faire mieux que les autres toujours
aller plus vite que les autres toujours
plus de contraintte plus de complexité
plus de contrôle et c'est exactement
cela que les agriculteurs nous crient
aujourd'hui la la vérité c'est que en
2019 ça n'est pas nouveau en 2019 la
France est devenue on ne le répètera
jamais assez la France est devenue
déficitaire commercialement sur sa
balance agricole si l'on retire les vins
et les spiritueux ça veut dire que en
réalité depuis 2019 nous sommes devenus
dépendants pour notre alimentation de ce
que produisent d'autres pays que nous
leur importons ça c'est le symptôme
d'une crise absolument inédite pour la
France parce que la France a des
territoires exceptionnels des terroirs
magnifiques des agriculteurs incroyables
et que nous soyons devenu incapable de
nous suffire à nous-même pour notre
propre alimentation de garder notre
sécurité alimentaire c'est le signe de
ce malaise profond dans lequel le monde
agricole se débat depuis trop longtemps
et qu'il est fallu en arriver là pour
qu'on les entende enfin c'est je crois
un immense échec collectif pour nous en
tous les cas depuis 4 ans nous avons
tiré le signal d'alarme nous nous sommes
battus avec ma collègue Ann Sander en
commission de l'agriculture au Parlement
européen contre cet agenda de contrainte
de complexité de contrôle qui fait des
agriculteurs des suspects
parmi ce qui problème il y a le pacte
vert il y a le fameux pacte vert qui est
porté par rosola Van Leon le pacte vert
qui est défendu par Rola van Leon qui
fait partie de votre famille politique
est-ce qu'il faut revenir là-dessus cela
vanlayen elle a été nommée par Emmanuel
Macron en tous les cas c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui a empêché notre candidat
Manfred Weber de devenir président de la
Commission européenne et Manfred Weber
c'est celui qui président de mon groupe
politique depuis 2 ans a décidé de la
nécessité de mettre fin à cette folie
normative qui a décidé que notre groupe
le PPE allait s'opposer de manière
déterminée à cet agenda et si cet agenda
a pu se mettre donc on revient sur le
pacte vert si le si le la la stratégie
dite de la ferme à la fourchette qui
prévoyait une baisse de la production
agricole en Europe autour de 15 % si
cette stratégie a pu se mettre en place
c'est parce qu'elle a trouvé une
majorité au Parlement européen cette
majorité elle va de l'extrême gauche en
passant par les socialistes et les Verts
jusqu'à nos collègues macronistes qui
ont soutenu avec détermination l'agenda
le plus radical en terme de contrainte
environnementale je pense par exemple à
notre collègue Pascal confin président
de la commission de l'environnement
député macroniste issu des rend des
Verts qui a porté cette stratégie qui a
porté par exemple un texte qui s'appelle
restauration de la nature qui est devenu
emblématique ce texte restauration de la
nature créer un chapitre entier de
nouvelles règles et de nouvelles normes
et notamment dans les dispositions
initiales de ce texte il y avait l'idée
qu'il fallait geler 10 % de la surface
agricole utile en Europe c'était une
folie nous nous sommes contre cette
folie avec tout notre groupe le PPE nous
avons voté contre ce texte nous avons
réussi à faire tomber de peu ce gel de
10% heureusement mais malheureusement le
reste du texte est passé il est passé à
12 voix près et aujourd'hui nous sommes
devant le vote qui doit avoir lieu du
texte final qui aura lieu dans un mois
j'ai une question toute simple à poser
au Premier ministre qui doit s'exprimer
aujourd'hui si vraiment le président de
la République prend au sérieux ce qu'il
dit si vraiment il veut sortir de la
France des tracas si vraiment il veut
sortir de la suradministration de la sur
bureaucratisation de la folie qui
organise cette décroissance agricole au
profit de modèle agrico qui détruisent
bien plus l'environnement dans les
paystiers et que nous importons de plus
en plus pour combler ce que nous ne
produisons plus nous-mêmes si vraiment
on veut sortir de cette spirale alors
que vont faire les députés macronistes
sur le texte restauration de la nature
au Parlement européen dans un mois la
question est simple elle est sur la
table et je crois qu'elle attend
maintenant une réponse donc ce sera un
test l'agriculture ce sera avec
l'immigration des thèmes centraux de la
campagne des européennes pour vous en
tout cas de la vôtre au-delà de
l'agriculture je crois que ce qu'on est
en train de vivre c'est la question
centrale pour la France est-ce que nous
voulons encore produire ce qui nous est
nécessaire nous nous le disons depuis le
début de ce mandat au Parlement européen
en fait c'est tous ceux qui produisent
dans ce pays qui sont suspects et les
agriculteurs j'étais dans l'Oise
aventière rencontrer des agriculteurs
hier je recevais des éleveurs laitiers à
Bruxelles qui nous racontent tous la
même chose aujourd'hui vous êtes un
agriculteur vous travaillez chez vous
sur vos TER vous avez un satellite qui
passe au-dessus de votre tête qui tous
les TR jours prend en photo ce que vous
êtes en train de faire et si il y a un
tas qui est posé au mauvais endroit vous
avez immédiatement un contrôle qui se
déclenche est-ce que on peut accepter
que ceux qui produisent en France soit
suspect considéré comme présumé coupable
c'est les agriculteurs mais c'est aussi
les pêcheurs auxquels Bruxelles a imposé
de travailler sous l'œil des caméras qui
filment leur activité c'est au fond nos
industriels qui sont soumis à des textes
des normes des règles de plus en plus
compliquées la désindustrialisation du
pays Bruno le disait très bien au Sénat
on a su on a vécu on a touché du doigt
ce que ça voulait dire est-ce qu'on va
vivre d'une certaine façon la fin de
tout le tissu productif français est-ce
qu'on va devenir définitivement un pays
de consommateur qui produit plus rien et
qui finance sa consommation avec de la
dette publique c'est ça qui est en train
de nous arriver éc soti vous a
officialisé il y a seulement quelques
jours comme tête de liste des
républicains est-ce que votre parti ne
vous a pas lancé trop tard dans cette
campagne comment vous faire entendre
entre Gabriel hatal et Jordan Bardella
d'abord la campagne ne fait que
commencer les élections européennes sont
en juin prochain ces élections elles
seront déterminantes pour l'avenir du
continent et et le match qu'on voudrait
installer en France entre monsieur hatal
et Monsieur Bardella je ve dire au
Parlement européen ça correspond à rien
dans les institutions européennees ça
n'existe pas au Parlement européen ce
qui existe vraiment c'est ce qui
structure la quasi-ttalité des
démocraties européennes le grand clivage
fondamental entre la droite et la gauche
mais est-ce que les Français vont voter
sur cet enjeu européenne ou est-ce
qu'ils vont faire une élection de que
nous allons réussir à mettre les enjeu
de fond sur la table parce que le défi
décisif pour nous c'est que la voix des
Français puisse peser au Parlement
européen aujourd'hui la macronie à
Bruxelles a décidé de devenir la force
supplétive de la gauche dans son projet
de décroissance à nous de faire en sorte
que les Français soient représentés par
une force politique qui permette
justement de reconstruire le contexte
normatif dont nous avons besoin de
reconstruire une Europe qui puisse nous
renforcer renforcer nos démocraties au
lieu de les affaiblir et c'est cela je
crois la grande question de l'élection
qui vient en juin prochain dans le
Figaro il y a quelques jours vous avez
dit que cette campagne engageait
beaucoup l'avenir de votre famille
politique ça peut être les la dernière
campagne des républicains non ça va être
la campagne de la reconstruction j'en
suis certain et avec éc Coti le travail
qui a été fait au cours des dernières
années pour faire en sorte que nous
retrouvions une ligne claire qui
peut-être avait manqué dans le passé
pour faire en sorte que nous retrouvions
un cap que nous soyons capable de nous
l'avons montré sur l'immigration le
texte sur l'immigration il a été voté
par tous les parlementaires les
républicains à l'Assemblée et au Sénat
encore une fois aujourd'hui le
gouvernement cherche un moyen détourn de
retirer ce résultat aux Français mais ça
n'empêche pas que nous soyons unis sur
ce sujet notre ligne ne déviera pas et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui cette élection
européenne peut être l'occasion de vivre
le début de de la refondation d'une
droite qui soit à la hauteur des enjeux
pour la France parce que c'est ça qui
compte d'abord ça n'est pas d'abord un
parti mais c'est évidemment le pays un
dernier mot puisque contrairement la
dernière fois il y aura en plus de la
liste du RN une liste reconquête Marion
maréchal il y a quelques jours disait
que vous devriez logiquement être avec
elle elle vous fait le reproche de
l'incohérence que lui répondez-vous au
contraire moi je je suis cohérent
constant clair j'ai tout toujours
défendu la même ligne je crois à la
nécessité de reconstruire une droite qui
soit je le disais à l'instant à la
hauteur de ces défis en Europe mais elle
a dit en gros vous êtes plus sur sa
ligne que sur la ligne des républicains
qui pour elle sont les alliés d'Emmanuel
Macron écoutez je vais pas me prononcer
à partir des des des questions que
posent des gens qui eux ont changé de
camp ont changé d'étiquettes ont changé
d'écurie ont changé de tactique voilà la
mienne est constante je suis engagé au
sein de cette famille politique pour
reconstruire la droite et je crois que
tous les Français qui aspirent à cette
refondation
viend nous soutenir à l'asion de cette
élection européne merci Fran merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin on va parler de la crise agricole
de l'immigration tout de suite dans le
club